you'd think there should be a cure for
the common cold scientists have been
working on cold viruses for over 70
years but they've never found an
effective cure the cold is the world's
most prevalent infectious disease adults
get between two and four colds a year
and children get way way more so this
means that you'll probably get over 200
colds in your lifetime and at any one
point hundreds of millions of people
around the world have a cold so we're
going to talk about why it's so
difficult to cure the cold in a moment
but before that we should go back to the
very first time we thought we were going
to cure it the golden age of cold
research starts in 1957 with a scientist
named Winston price at Johns Hopkins
University price is the first person to
ever isolate a cold virus at a
laboratory and this is a really big deal
because while people had described the
symptoms of a cold for thousands of
years nobody had ever found the agent
that causes it so price becomes sort of
like a minor scientific celebrity and he
then announces that he's going to create
a vaccine for it but the vaccine doesn't
work very well it only protects against
a very very small proportion of
infections and price has no idea why now
this is pretty disappointing but it's
good to think about what's going on in
science at the time people are
incredibly incredibly optimistic about
the potential for research and
especially medical research the polio
vaccine had just been created in 1955
and it's the dawn of the age of
antibiotics and after the Second World
War
governments are really really keen to
invest in ambitious projects with
definite goals that solve big problems
in society and so the cold becomes one
of these things and a huge amount of
funding comes out of the problem it
moves beyond prices lab and cold
research centers open across the entire
world and my favorite one of these is
the common cold research unit in
Salisbury in England so the scientists
there put ads in the local paper
basically advertising a two-week
vacation in the countryside as long as
you were willing to be locked in a
drafty corridor or to huff bags of cold
infected air and let scientists observe
you for a couple of hours every day and
so what scientists unpick over the next
thirty years from all of this is that
the cold isn't caused by one virus it's
caused by seven different viral families
and each one has subtypes which are
called serotypes which are recognized
differently by the immune system and so
this is why the coldest OD
to cure and it's why prices vaccine
never worked it was only for the one
cold family and one sera type he had
isolated the problem is at the time that
this is all known in the 1980s vaccine
technology could only fit in a few
serotypes per injection without causing
an enormous immune response and so you
basically have the science that we know
at an impasse with the technology at the
time and people have been working on
colds for almost a generation 25 or 30
years and the scientific imagination has
a tendency to wonder elite biologists
and government funding start moving more
into other projects like aids which is
incredibly deadly and almost a total
mystery at the time and so colds kind of
go out of favor as a topic of research
and the common cold unit even shudders
in 1990
since then we've gotten way better at
dealing with infectious diseases we've
eradicated smallpox gotten measles mumps
rubella tetanus whooping cough all kinds
of things under control and so cold
research has undergone a bit of a
renaissance lately there's two totally
different approaches that are both quite
promising in the UK there's a group
that's taking a look at every single
cold sarah type and trying to find a
piece in common that they can target a
vaccine to it's quite like an elegant
direct approach and then there's an
American company who's trying to create
a super vaccine so this would be one
shot with all 50 of the most common cold
serotypes in it it's sort of a
brute-force approach but despite the
promise of all this research there's
still one big hurdle to getting it
finished and that has more to do with
the business of science than science
itself
the thing is vaccines are very good bets
for pharmaceutical companies they're
incredibly expensive to develop and
failure rates are really high even late
in trials takes about a billion American
dollars and almost a decade to develop a
successful vaccine of all the thousands
of pharmaceutical companies that there
are only about five work on vaccines
really seriously and these are the
biggest and richest companies and when
it comes down to it would you really get
an expensive injection just to avoid a
few days discomfort I probably wouldn't
so even after all the progress over the
past seventy years will probably
continue to suffer from colds
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon